on va commencer avec un film où vos
propos de d'intellectuels pour ciné club
de quartier notre interlocuteur vont
pouvoir se déchaîner le retour du jedi
ouais ouais qui commet ce genre parodie
mon combat c'est qu'il ya vraiment il ya
pas grand chose à raconter sauf que
c'est un film qui fait pour les moufles
et ça y'a pas de problème
la première heure n'est pas mal dans la
mesure où elle a pas mal d'invention ce
terme et d'une collection une galerie de
monstres qui est assez impressionnant
notamment une espèce de montagne obèses
et visqueuse et éructant tu qui est très
porté sur les choses du sexe avec les
dames et qui comme il n'aime pas les
humanoïdes masculin les sur jelle un peu
comme viva gel bien sûr et il ya une
mamie nova donc à toute cette galerie
comme si le type qui les a inventés
disais voilà je vais vous montrer ce que
je sais faire et alain notamment qui moi
qui m'a fait cauchemarder carrément le
lendemain c'est un trou dans ça se passe
dans le désert et un trou dans le sol et
dans ce trou il ya des milliers de
langues de l'ue est de papilles et si
vous tombez dedans on s'avoue digère
pendant mille ans qui est vraiment une
une éventualité extrêmement délicieuse
bon on a tout de suite après 7h
d'invention 16 bat karé ment parce que
ça devient la gué guerre interstellaire
alors ça ressemble aux petits jeux vidéo
qu'on voit dans les grands magasins en
plus grand bien entendu ou alors ça
ressemble aussi à ces interminables et
inévitable feuilleton à la télé ou des
machines qui ressemble à des boîtes de
conserves cabossé se tape sur la gueule
ça devient extrêmement lassant moi ce
qui m'étonne c'est que ça marche si bien
qu'ils aient des adultes pour ne pas
tomber raide mort d'ennui ya simplement
une chose que j'aime bien en sus et
qu'on retrouve nos deux vieux copains là
les robots notamment art ou du tout qui
ressemble à un aspirateur traîneau et
qui crépite ses émotions et un autre qui
était une forme d'humanoïdes qui est
doré qui a l'air d'une folle tordue
équipe avec un délicieux accent de
d'oxford bon en dehors
on est très content d'y retrouver
malheur en dehors de ça c'est vraiment
deux heures de perdues alors genre est
ce qu'il ya vraiment un érotisme torride
dans ce retour du jedi comme
me semble le dire odile lorsque deal
parle d'ennui elle traduit très
exactement l'impression que j'ai eue
devant une salle qui naturellement était
comble étant donnée la fabuleuse
publicité qui a été fait autour de ce
film
mais toute cette immense foule était
plongé dans une sorte de torpeur et
véritablement il n'y a eu qu'une seule
réaction et elle m'a énormément surpris
une énorme
hilarité quand les deux rôles à la
princesse leia et le brillant au look je
complète comme ça lorsqu'il déclara sas
il déclare la princesse qui levait son
frère pourquoi est ce qu'ils ont le
public a trouvé ça extrêmement drôle
c'est qu'il s'était sans doute l
m'ennuyer jusque-là canfin eelv y avait
quelque chose à peu près qu'on crie
alors odile également à parler de ses
poupées de ces maquettes qui ressemble
extrait exactement à celles qu'on voit
dans les vitrines de noël dans les
grands magasins
il n'y a absolument aucune espèce
d'invention ce sont deux feux nounours
de faux crapaud de foz éléphants de
fausses âge etc
alors là là où vraiment je suis
stupéfait c'est qu'ayant des moyens
fabule george lucas disposant de a
vraiment de toute la technologie
d'hollywood
cette technologie soit au niveau le plus
bas
alors que la véritable technologie celle
qui est appuyée sur la science s'est
envoyé dans l'espace
des missiles qui vont au delà du système
solaire savent créer des puces d'un
millimètre carré qui contiennent de
dizaines de milliers d'informations
c'est ça le fantastique moderne ce qu'on
nous montre sur l'écran c'est rien
c'est insignifiant par rapport à la
réalité que nous voyons tous les jours
sur les écrans de télévision
moi je suis absolument stupéfait que ces
gens là semblent vivre en vase clos à
fabriquer leurs petits gadgets personnel
sans jamais regarder ce que font les
véritables savants et les véritables
techniciens qui ont bouleversé notre
univers alors salle 101 un film qui nous
plonge dans des abîmes
et si comme je n'en doute pas il obtient
en france autant de succès qu'en
amérique ça prouvera que le public n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait aussi évoluer
que nous voudrions que nous le
souhaiterions bien jacques fieschi vous
avez vu leur tournée des dingues
oui je l' ai vu je suis un petit peu
moins sévère que jean charensol je suis
d'accord c'est un cinéma souvent inepte
amnésique régressif c'est vrai mais il
me semble aussi que
le casse a trouvé au coeur du pop corn
une certaine force mythologique qui est
un peu celle du compte parfois voilà je
vais trouver la première
enfin la guerre des étoiles absolument
affligeante
déjà j'étais beaucoup plus intéressés
par l'empiré contre attaque et là je
trouve qu'il y a une certaine invention
quand même les ressources nul bien sûr
sauf la princesse qui a une certaine
maturité elle se trouve
car elle est belle il regarde ses deux
enfants débiles comme ça avec un air
adultes mais l'itinéraire de luke
skywalker la recherche du père comme ça
c'est un semblant de consistance à ses
marionnettes non charensol a parlé de
torpeur du public moi je crois que sa
torpeur qu'il qu'il est réel je tiens
surtout à l'utilisation intensive du son
dolby
il est vrai que le submergé par un
torrent de décibels et je crois que ce
qu'on aimerait quand on assiste à la
projection du film en salles avec le
public qui a une moyenne d'âge de 15 ans
on aimerait qu'il y ait une réaction de
cette salle que ce soit comme un vieux
mélodrame où les gens crient attention
lorsque le héros va être surpris par le
trader et ses parents on est max
applaudissent que ça criait hourrah aux
pertes personne n'en a le loisir parce
qu'il ya tellement de bruit n'est ce pas
qu'on n'entend absolument pas la même
réaction c'est pas possible on est
submergés il ya déjà ça je trouve ça
excessif
deuxièmement c'est vrai que c'est assez
ennuyeux et ça ça manque d' inventions
il ya c'est un film qui est fait sur la
mobilité sur l'extrême vitesse on va
plus vite que la lumière etc
quand on va plus vite que la lumière il
arrive qu'on n'ait plus rien à montrer
c'est un peu gênant dans le film
justement on en arrive toujours à
retrouver les mêmes effets
d'accélérations brusques du mouvement du
mouvement des appareils de transport des
choses comme ça donc c'est ce sont des
effets répéter continuellement
je pense aussi que
on aurait pu et ça je crois que dans le
deuxième de la série qui est le meilleur
l'empiré contre attaque qui d'ailleurs
signé par un metteur en scène qui n'est
pas indifférent qu'ils étaient en vie
car shna il y avait un imaginaire
beaucoup plus riches
or là cet imaginaire est extrêmement
pauvre on voudrait qu'il y ait une que
la vitesse soit dans les idées dans les
trouvailles que ce soit une cascade de
trouvailles permanente or ça n'est pas
le cas la vitesse elle est seulement
dans les a faits alors parfois ça c'est
très réussi
il ya une espèce de course de motos
volantes de scooter volant dans une
forêt de séquoias une espèce de
labyrinthes d'arbres qui est vraiment à
couper le souffle ça c'est très très
réussie c'est ce que j'aime beaucoup
mais en face on en reste à ses effets
physiques
[Musique]